Our goal was to conquer North America, then every single continent on Earth.
We've succeeded.
It's true, we've started a bit late in the game but we're catching up.
We will find every nook and cranny they missed and eat them up.
But, shh! They don't know that.
They can't fool us, we know what they're up to.
What they don't know...
...is we're forming the R&D of new technology that will let us take over the galaxy.
That's right, the galaxy.
We know about their galaxy plans.
Ha! One step ahead, dude.
Did anyone hear about the universe?
Ha! The universe? What a joke.
Here's the real secret:...
...something bigger than the universe is out there...
...and we know the person who runs it.
Hey! I have a phone now too.
Boo!